hi guys thank you for coming to this
talk my name is Jeff trattner I work at
Council which is a company that does DNA
testing so like if you're thinking of
having kid or something like that you
send us your DNA and we sequence it and
then tell you about your results and we
use pandas there for some of our data
munging tasks but the kind of the reason
that I am talking about this in
particular is because for a while is a
very active contributor to pandas
overall so yeah and actually I'm really
excited to be here in particular because
PI data NYC in 2013 was the place where
I got my first job in tech so it's like
really exciting to be able to be on the
other side and give them some cool talks
so just let's hold on so to quickly talk
about pandas so it's like a really large
project so you can see that there's like
12,000 commits there's about like 200
thousand lines of code four hundred
contributors which is awesome because
many of them are people who like put up
one PR and something small and like
contribute in and it's really great it's
I think it's one of the just a really
amazing community it's been around for
about six years and you can see like the
development activity has shifted a lot
you know West makini the person who
started it was really active and now
jeffrey back has been doing an awesome
job i am sort of number nine on this
list and kind of tailed off of my
commits but i still have some memory of
pandas overall and so with this big
history with this huge codebase with all
this stuff it can be like a little
intimidating to figure out what's going
on behind the scenes with pandas so what
i'm gonna try to do here overall is give
you like a little bit of orientation
into some of the really key concepts and
pandas so that if you want to dive
deeper you kind of have this like
high-level idea of what you want to be
doing so kind of like we're gonna give
you like guide posts and stuff like that
so i'm gonna just do a little more
introduction then i'm gonna give kind of
a background into the many python data
analysis libraries that pandas kind of
works on top of because there's you know
just a bunch of them and also talked
about like why
wrangling data in Python you can't just
do it at like a pure Python level like
why we have these specialized libraries
to do it and then I'm going to talk
about some of the really fundamental
pandas concepts from the implementation
side so indexing grouping and storing
data and finally in terms of factorizing
overall which is like sort of used a lot
to the pandas Cove ace so these aren't
obviously aren't all the things the
pandas does but they're sort of
important areas and I think getting a
little insight into them will give you a
different sense of the library and also
help understand maybe why certain things
are fast or slow or considerations that
you want to have so let's start out so
again lots of lines of code it depends
on many other libraries and we're going
to talk about sort of the key concepts
so I just want to like take a moment I
know I've like said this twice but the
pandas community is amazing it's like
one of the most welcoming open-source
communities I've been a part of so if
you feel at all like hey something
should be better with pandas or I really
wish pandas did this I really encourage
you to go out and like try to contribute
to it because it can be a really great
learning experience and it's really fun
and it's like a great feeling when your
code ends up somewhere so go contribute
so I'm hoping that most of you guys have
a sense of pandas like how many people
have at least heard of pandas before
this ok awesome so I would hope so but
so overall I think that the key thing
that pandas does is it provides a really
flexible API over data and in particular
labelled data so if you're if you're
thinking about numpy it might be more
about like integer index and stuff like
that whereas pandas is more concerned
with like I have this metadata and I
want to be able to use that to group
select combined filter and transform my
data and then also it has a really big
component that I'm not really going to
talk about much here of getting data in
and out you can go from a whole bunch of
different formats to another set of
formats very easily and transparently so
it makes it really easy to get data in
there and it also works well with other
Python data analysis libraries but the
context for this is making it easy to
manipulate data in a fast and performant
way so let's let's talk quickly about
like what is kind of going on behind the
scenes in Python that's kind of
contributing to why Python slow so
python is
SuperDuper flexible right like you can
set a property on an object you can
override addition multiplication
division literally everything and you
can do that and it's great but it also
means that when you see something kind
of simple like this like this particular
thing it looks really simple right
you're like iterating over an array on
every element you're maybe taking the
log of it you're doing some
multiplication like this seems like
something that shouldn't be that big of
a deal but the thing is that because
python is so dynamic and flexible this
translates into these kind of operations
behind the scenes so the way you should
interpret this is that this is kind of
the way that python compiles it to a
list of commands right so you see the
loop starting there's some loading of
names which basically means like okay I
got to go look in the global namespace
and up and up and up until it finds the
definition of it or throws a name error
but one thing you can look at at
particular is look at how because you're
using I two times in this loop there's
no like cashing there's no hey I totally
know that this eye is gonna be used
twice instead it's just like I'm gonna
have to look it up every time and
similarly with the log function it has
to be looked up every time and that's
partially because you can write a
function that literally changes the
global namespace so the next time you
call that function it's different or the
same thing with properties on objects so
all of this sort of Dynamis 'ti it
causes a lot of overhead a look up in a
dictionary is fundamentally expensive
but when we're talking about expensive
here I just want to be really clear that
we're talking about that and the concept
of like arrays that have hundreds of
thousands of elements or millions of
elements so when you're thinking about
hey I want to add one to every one of
those things if you have to do this look
up every single time when you're doing
it a hundred thousand times or a million
times that's when that overhead of
looking up a function of looking up a
value starts to get really high so one
way that you can avoid this overhead is
with the Python C API so it's kind of
like let's you choose when you want to
bubble up to the Python level and other
taught the number talk in particular
talked about some ways to avoid the Gil
but for and so that lets you write code
at the C level and get some like nice
optimizations a lot more control over
memory management and stuff like that
another component so it's kind of just
like there is a way to
interact with code at the C level and
the Python C API is is non-trivial so
I'm just gonna kind of hand wave there
but the other part of this that happens
too is that individual Python objects
have a lot of memory overhead so if you
think about like a C integer an array in
C is literally just a set of boxes like
at some level that are sized exactly for
the data that's inside of it but when
you're thinking about it at the Python
level there's a lot of overhead that
goes into here so this PI object head
that you see here on this slide
oops that is that involves a lot of the
bookkeeping that python does so you
don't have to manage memory so a
reference count which gets incremented
every time you say a equals B or stuff
like that the type of the variable which
impacts like how lookups happen and then
finally the value itself or maybe a
pointer to the value so that means again
if we're thinking about this on the
level of hundreds of thousands of Python
objects every one of them has to have
this overhead and these images are from
Jake van der placid is awesome why
Python is slow which is a great blog
post that kind of goes more in depth
into it so I'm just kind of stealing
them to make for a better summary so
this particular issue comes up even more
when you're thinking about a Python list
where every single element where the
list itself is an object so it has that
overhead and then every element in the
list is a pointer to another Python
object and so the problem that happens
there is that you have this array that
when you go over it every time you're
gonna have to do lookup which means that
you know if you kind of see how crazy
these lines cross and stuff like that
that means that maybe you're gonna break
the CPU cache or you're gonna need to be
loading in different ways and no matter
what that all adds additional overhead
so that's like kind of another component
of the things that we want to avoid and
one of the ways that we can make this
better is by using an umpire array so an
umpire array is essentially like around
and again this is like super high level
but is around basically lets you have
that value of a C integer where like
boxes are exactly sized to every
component but still be able to interact
with it in Python and C and Fortran and
so now that you have like kind of the
data locality that you want you're not
sort of crossing over between CPU and
and you you know can do better cache
performance and things like that so
numpy overall it's enabling like fast
vectorized operations on a race so it's
a pointer to memory and Fortran there's
a lot of scientific code that was
written a long time ago in Fortran like
plaids and lapak and I think Atlas that
are really sturdy there it's written
very well it's well optimized and so
numpy lets you pass in these arrays to
those kind of functions to get those
sort of performance optimizations while
still being able to write Python code
and so this this idea of vectorization
to be clear is just like you do some
operation on every element in an array
so that you can stay under the Python
level and not incur sort of the overhead
of having to look up a particular
function or a value or something like
that okay so but the issue with numpy
like Travis said in his talk on number
is that you have to write functions for
it in C and that's kind of a bummer
because then you have to handle memory
management and you have to handle you
know all the different ways that things
can go wrong and cross system
compatibility so the next kind of level
that we're adding here in addition to
numpy is siphon so siphon is this subset
or sort of like a version of Python
that's tight and because it's typed it
lets you be able to express really
elegantly sort of transformations with
numpy but without having to necessarily
write all the bookkeeping code for it so
we have this like particularly lookup
function like this you can see that it
has the sort of C def part is saying
here's the types of the things that I'm
going to be using and you're very
explicit about it and then this for loop
and things like that get translated and
you can even inline functions you can
call C functions and then if you need to
go up the Python level for something
then you can do that and so the output
of Scion is super complicated
it ends up compiling to this C code
where the comments are like each
individual line where you're seeing
what's going on and I just want to like
if you take this part right here you see
how many lines there are here this is
kind of like a representation in C code
of how much bookkeeping there has to
have around Python stuff now this is
more kind of the bookkeeping about
making sure that you've accessed an
array appropriately like you haven't had
overflow you haven't done various other
things like that but all of that
bookkeeping is what's happening under
the scenes every time we do a list
subset or ever
time you're talking about reference
counts or things like that but then if
we look at like this line here this KH
get in 32 is actually this library Caleb
that will talk a little bit of more
about later
that's a C function and because you're
at sea level you're using a value that
psyphon knows is able to be passed that
function and everything like that you
can actually call it directly and see
which means that when GCC compiles this
or whatever compiler you're using
compiles it you can get the kind of
compiler optimizations that you want and
you also get to like have very better
memory management and stuff like that
so that's kind of scythe on so then we
have scythe on we have numpy and then
another level that comes on top of that
again for more optimization is I
actually don't know how to pronounce
this but I think it's numb expert or
numb expression and basically what that
does is it lets you say okay I want to
do this complicated set of operations on
an umpire right so generally if you take
this formula right here like 2 times a
plus 3 times B what happens if you do
that at Python level is 2 times 8
happens and then that forms an
intermediate array and then probably 3
times B happens next so that's an
intermediate array and then you add them
together and that forms yet another
intermediate array so what num
expression does and this gets used in
pandas to optimize some of the slow
parts is basically say okay I totally
know that on this for loop I'm gonna be
doing all these operations on every
element so instead of going up and down
and doing copies I'm just gonna stay at
this lower level and work on buckets of
the array doing all the operations at
once which gives you the ability to not
have as many temporary copies so in
terms of bytecode why's that ends up
looking sort of more like this which is
where like each component is some chunk
of it that it works on and does these
operations without having intermediate
copies so this is sort of like another
level of sort of the many layers of
stuff that pandas is on top of so if we
just stopped here we would have like a
really great thing we'd have we have
numpy that has good data locality and
fast performant operations like sine
cosine addition things like that we have
scythe on which lets us write universal
functions for numpy and we have num
expression or in many other libraries
like it there's another one called
bottleneck that lets you compile numpy
basically compile and
your operations you could even use
number and stuff like that so the
question here is like why would you ever
use pandas on top of that and and I
think probably you guys have some sense
of why that would be but the basic
reason is that all of those things are
great when you want to optimize code in
particular but the sweet spot would be
being able to have heterogeneous data
types so not just saying ahead of time
I have an ende array and it's in 32 and
it has 20 elements but being able to
sort of write code that's very generic
and be able to have easy missing data
handling and basically be able to deal
with label data in a way where you don't
have to specialize for every single kind
of thing that you're doing
so in particular here what we're talking
about is that you can load something
from a CSV have no idea what the data
format is inside of it but still take
advantage of kind of the optimized
algorithms and routines that Penn does a
numpy and number expression and all of
those different levels provide so that's
kind of like the overall reason that
pandas exists and is useful is to be
flexible in that way so and and and I
think that most the point that is most
relevant for pandas is that it provides
a better sense of labelled data because
essentially like if you're thinking
about a numpy array an umpire array
thinks that okay integer index zero
integer index one integer Nexus two
that's what's important about this
whereas pandas we're talking about the
index as this element that's really
important so that's kind of so that
leads into this next section when we're
talking about indexing that's a really
important pandas operation that
underlies a lot of the stuff that's
going on it's the way that you transform
something where there's a set of labels
that you care about from a business
perspective or from user perspective to
the set of like elements from this array
that numpy needs to work on so we have
this core patent structure that's a data
frame just to like make sure everybody's
on the same page so indexes are kind of
the columns and the rows and just to I'm
just gonna as an aside here
pandas supports like multi-dimensional
data sets right you could have like
three dimensions four dimensions but
honestly like it all is kind of the same
idea so I'm just gonna stick with the
data frame when we're talking about this
stuff because it's just a lot easier to
think about so you have indexes you have
like the internal data that's stored in
those indexes and that the columns and
rows represent and then individual
columns we kind of
call serious so it's like a one
dimensional data frame so we're talking
about kind of the basics of indexing the
big issue is that indexes are a big
mapping so let's say that like ABCD or
some list of products or a/b tests or
something like that basically the main
thing that the index does is when you
say I want to see it says internally ok
that's and that's indexed - that's like
the main role that an index does but
that's sort of complicated once you get
to more things like alignment and
merging and joining but that's like kind
of the key thing to keep in mind it's
like a big nicht mapping labels to
integer indexes so you want to read this
as like Rosi maps location - it's sort
of the metadata on a data frame that we
care about and then obviously like you
can convert any series into an index so
like kind of that's just the overall
thing and then a really key point is
that indexes are immutable and that kind
of matters at some level because it
means that you can share indexes between
components and you can do a lot of kind
of expensive work behind the scenes to
construct an index so okay again task
one lookups you have some label you look
it up you end up with values on top of
it so this is like you're saying locks
see which means are going to get that
row if I said quantity I get like 523
200 148 with that index now the next
task that indexes do that I think you
kind of like intuitively understand but
maybe yeah I definitely didn't
necessarily think about what the heck
was going on behind the scenes is taking
to different data frames that have
similar metadata in other words we're
saying that this first data frame and
the second data frame are still
referencing the same ideas they're
referencing the same set of products and
the columns that are there mean the same
kind of values but we want to be able to
combine them so for numpy is perspective
the only thing that matters in general
is ordering or maybe you pass like an
array of indices to numpy as well but
it's not necessarily as transparent as
pandas is where you just say a plus B so
what the index is gonna do here with
these two data frames is make them
compatible so let's say we're thinking
about adding these two together so take
a second and think in your head like
what do you think the output should be
like if you're thinking about if you use
pandas already you know but like what
does it mean that for example points is
missing from the second one how do you
end up with a data frame
combining the two of them or the fact
that like row F is missing from the
second part or they're in a different
order so if you know pandas what ends up
happening is that you have n a n which
means like missing values in the third
column there's no points in them so it
doesn't mean anything to combine them
there's no row F so in the output that
also doesn't mean anything and then you
also notice that it's like reordered so
let's think about how that alignment
happens because basically what's going
on behind the scenes the first step is
to say okay I need to get this into a
format so I can pass to numpy arrays to
numpy it to the handle like the
optimized part so what needs to happen
here is we just need to use the indexes
to be able to get them in the same
format so then we can combine the
columns so basically the sort of get
index or method what's really
responsible for is the same goal of the
index we talked about before taking a
label and ending up with a set of
integer locations but in this case it's
going to be the set of integer locations
that you can use with that second data
frame that will give you the same
ordering with it that'll give you like
the right ordering to be able to combine
with that so so basically if you're
looking at the first item and saying
okay I hey where is that on the second
index that's at index one B's at index 3
season index 2 and so forth and then the
problem is when you hit like a missing
value what that ends up getting
representatives is negative one that's
just sort of like a convention so that
when you end up with the aligned data
frame and I kind of when I made this up
I just tried to keep the quantity the
same as the index just so you can see it
you end up with it basically reordered
so that it matches the order of the
other data frame so that's kind of like
what indexing is doing and I know again
this is something where it's like sort
of straightforward but also I think when
you think about kind of how these pieces
are split apart it makes it easier to
understand why there's so much crazy
code around indexing because if the
indexes can manage this transformation
well then other parts of pandas like
don't have to be concerned with that ok
so the next thing that's going on here
is you think about like this is like a
five element thing right you have to do
like five lookups but again when we're
talking about this we're talking about
this on the scale of like really huge
indexes so maybe 10,000 items or 5,000
items or or larger than that please she
becomes if it actually were a dict
behind the scenes
you still have that same issue of oh my
gosh here's Python functions there's
objects I'm going up and down in level
so the question is like how do you
handle that so if you do if you want to
do tons of lookups really fast the
Python dict implementation is actually
pretty fast so that was kind of what
what what lesson can you use to start
with but now what pandas uses behind the
scenes is this C library called Caleb
and I don't have like a great picture of
it but basically what you should imagine
that Caleb does is it has an internal
dick representation that's very fast and
that you can do all that sea level and
the other thing that it does is lets you
say here's the type that I have I will
make a really specific typed dick that
is expected to work exactly like that
type so there's an int 32 dict and a
float dick and and and that kind of
stuff and what that lets you do behind
the scenes is it lets the compiler do
all the kind of optimizations again so
this lets basically what happens is that
you know it's specialized by type and
what this lets you do is like when we do
alignment behind the scenes it's
literally just iterating over every
index in one of the indexes and grabbing
the value from the mapping in the other
index and that's fast enough to be able
to do it on like even a really big index
and so if you remember before from that
site on slide we have that KH get in 32
that's kind of what ends up being later
through the code our calls to the Caleb
by race or the Caleb functions that pull
out from a mapping so also we were
talking before or I mentioned before
that indexes are immutable overall and
that's why this is important because
building up this mapping is expensive
it's expensive to iterate through every
item and factorize it and put in a value
so an index under the hood shares the
individual mapping each time so you even
though you have a different Python
object so you can manipulate the name
and stuff like that they're kind of
behind the scenes part is shared between
them okay so that's kind of like the
basics of indexing and like you know a
part of the problem here is that I would
love to go way more in depth but I kind
of want you guys to have a sense of like
you know here are the components so that
when you go and look at this if you
wanted to go look at this indexing code
and you see like hey there like 20
functions that all have underlines and
their names and they're doing crazy
stuff you can keep in your head like
yeah okay all I'm trying to get to you
is
integer indexes and be able to kind of
think about it through there so let's
imagine that we have some data in a CSV
so there's something like this like a
timestamp UID a product whatever just
some set of data that we want to load in
so if we loaded this with like the csv
module in Python right you'd end up with
just a bunch of strings and then it
would be hard to convert it you have to
write some specialized functions things
like that so pen des has essentially
like relatively optimized code
specifically for parsing CSVs and then
more broadly for parsing data overall so
the C engine for CSV is in general is
basically just a reader that lets you
specify a subset of columns so that you
know I guess if you have like a really
huge CSV you can read like three columns
and or something like that but kind of
the magic that's going on behind the
scenes that can actually be sort of
problematic when you want to have really
performant code is that the readers in
pandas will try to convert types so if
we go back to this like thing here
basically what's gonna happen is that
like for every row it's gonna try to
convert this to an int once it finds out
that doesn't work stops try to convert
it to a float when it finds out that
doesn't work stops try to convert it to
a bool etc the same thing with like na
values and similarly it tries to do date
parsing to be able to say okay I see
that this like it you know looks like a
date that I kind of know about let me
try and convert it so I think for really
big data frames it's only gonna take
like you know maybe the first whatever a
number of thousand rows and go over that
and usually I mean if you think about it
you can generally get to that pretty
quickly but one issue that comes into
play is that pandas can only give you a
value if it's compatible with like every
element so for example if you have a
column and every single entry is you
know an integer except for one row
that's a string well when you're
converting it back in it's gonna all
have to be strings so it all fits there
so that's kind of like what's going on
behind the scenes when you're reading in
data and then so like Excel uses the
same thing so okay so now we have this
data that's converted into you know the
right type and at this point you could
kind of think of it as being like a dict
mapping columns to ng arrays like okay I
figured out that the timestamp column
was a date so now I have like you know
the label and then I have like a array
of date times well think times 60 for an
S which is the numpy type but what
happens behind the whole
it is actually sort of similar to what
to the talk earlier today the data gets
split up into blocks by type so what can
happen is like all the columns that have
string values get grouped together and
all the columns that have integer values
get grouped together and so on and so
forth and the reason why you'd want to
do this it's basically that it's it's
kind of that same well there's a couple
reasons but one of the biggest reasons
is that like you can't numpy operations
are again set up to work on like
multi-dimensional arrays big groupings
so if you're thinking about hey I want
to do some operation across like three
columns storing it in this way lets you
do that operation without a copy because
again one of the big things about these
blocks and about numpy arrays is that
they have to be a fixed size so numpy
needs to know ahead of time what the
sizes which means that if you want to
use like three columns together to be
able to pass that into a function in
numpy you're gonna have to combine that
all behind the scenes so instead what
happens is that they sort in blocks and
so there's a block manager that handles
converting the request like for an index
like I want values ABC whatever to kind
of more internal sort of stuff so it's
folk so the block manager is more
focused on like getting the data and
also like directing changes to the right
row whereas the blocks are kind of
specialized by each type and if you look
at these blocks here right like these
ones don't have indexes that represent
the labels that you care about they're
all integer indexes whoops so what that
means is that you're going to end up
being able to write operations on blocks
that only care about getting those
integer indexes and stuff like that so
again let's you kind of have this like
separation of concerns granted if you go
look at the code that separation is not
perfect but it certainly is like kind of
you know a way of translating it so this
is like one of those points where I
think understanding that behind the
scenes there are fixed size blocks and
pandas let's you actually understand why
some of the operations can seem so weird
so one thing in particular that happens
with pandas is copying happens a lot
right so basically like if you end up
copying data that can be really
problematic if like your data takes up
half your
so if you're thinking about like what
stuff you can do to just keep a slice as
opposed to a copy thinking about blocks
is the big thing so when you're slicing
within a D type you can keep one so by D
pipe I just mean like within one set of
blocks you can keep that kind of slice
because in numpy if you specify like a
slice of values then it says okay all I
need to do now is take this pointer that
was pointing of the head of the list and
just say now it only has four elements
as opposed to like ten or something so
you end up with a view and that's like a
whole other complicated thing that I
don't really have time to go into but
you can sort of just so you end up with
like a slice so when you're slicing
within a single D type you can just like
say okay I want like this group of
things it gives you back of you it's
great for the problem because that
becomes that when you have crop when you
have like multiple a slice that crosses
D types or a slice that does fancy
indexing where you can no longer like
have that like direct mapping you end up
needing to copy and the the crosstie
type stuff is I think more just because
like the bookkeeping sort of more
complicated but so overall it's like
that is maybe if there's like one thing
you can take away from this talk it's
like slicing in a single D type versus
across multiple is different and then
also if you guys have been using an
older version of pandas and then
recently upgraded to like 0.15 or 0.16
you probably have hit setting with copy
as like a really crummy thing that crops
up and it's confusing and stuff like
that and this is sort of like one way to
understand what the heck that's setting
with copy errors means so what that's
saying is that underneath the hood
sometimes when you slice you can be
manipulating the same block but if you
slice in a way where you're causing a
copy to happen then all of the changes
that you're making to that other data
frame aren't going to be reflected in
the block manager because it is a
different block manager with a different
set of data and a different set of
copies so the goal here basically that
air is just to make you aware so that if
by accident your code that references
calm and calm see suddenly changes to be
like oh those are now two different D
types you don't have this like magical
confusing error that's going on behind
the scenes so the other thing that
pandas developers talk about a lot is
that
pens are expensive that in other words
like you think with the Python list
you're like oh yeah I want to add an
element I will just append to it and you
don't really think about like pre
allocating so blocks again and also like
sort of the stuff with numpy are the
reason why appending ends up being
expensive in other words like if you a
pen an element suddenly you've taken
your fixed size block that used to be
like 10 by 10 and now you want to make
it 11 by 10 and in numpy that's
something that has to result in the copy
you have to copy it from one place to
another and you know basically if you're
think about this like that's I mean it
should be pretty straightforward it's
just like yep that's like a property of
numpy but the other thing is that if you
wanted to say like allocate additional
data you you hit this issue that because
copying is happening behind the scenes
in pandas allocating bigger blocks just
by default would also be problematic
would also start eating up more of your
memory and have like different set of
performance considerations so like ways
to deal with it
basically you can like you can yourself
pre-allocate memories like zero out
spaces to start with or you can pull
everything out into python or you can
also just build up a bunch of individual
frames then concatenate them so you only
suffer a copy once okay so that was like
one key area pandas storing data getting
data we've talked about indexing too
which is sort of like the other really
important pandas operation and alignment
so for this last part I just want to
talk about like so group I is a really
cool key pandas thing it's really
elegant it's flexible it's usually
pretty performant so I'm just gonna talk
about kind of the algorithm that
underlies that because I think it's kind
of cool and Wes makinia has a talk from
PI data NYC in 2012 that goes a little
more in-depth so I'm just gonna kind of
cover the highlights of it because I
really want to give you guys time to ask
me any questions or whatever if
anything's confusing so so factorizing
basically means mapping repeated keys to
integers so it sort of looks like this
you're gonna iterate over an array and
every time you see a new element you
assign it like 1 then 2 then 3 then 4
then 5 so you end up with a mapping of a
dictionary of essentially like this
particular factor like means this value
or something like that so you can like
map the way I think I might have I think
I flipped one part of this and it should
be factors max 5
treacle zelans but no no that's right
and then you end up with a set of
indexes that map those those things back
so you have essentially you end up with
a couple decks behind the scenes so you
use this in a bunch of places again
group I uses this in other words to have
like a set I'll kind of show a little
more like why this matters uses this to
basically say okay I want to do a
grouping operation but instead of having
to write a separate algorithm for floats
and for Strings or for multiple columns
or stuff like that I only need to write
one algorithm that assumes that I have a
list of integers that say how things are
grouped plus the data that I care about
grouping so that's kind of like what's
going on here categoricals or another
area where this kind of factorizing
comes into play because you basically
instead of having like a string column
with like a hundred thousand entries
each of them repeated you can store it
as an integer column which is like a lot
smaller and also has some performance
benefits that again I don't have time to
go into and this is another area where
you just use Caleb to take advantage of
faster performance and the ability to
stay down to the sea level so let's
think about like why this is useful so
the the one really cool thing to think
about with this is just counting sort so
essentially what this is is a sort that
lets you avoid doing n log n comparisons
because basically if you know that you
have like low cardinality in the
particular like array that you're using
if you know that you have maybe a
hundred thousand items and only 10,000
them are unique or probably like a
little smaller than that you can
actually change how you're doing the
comparisons so that you don't have to
compare each element so in other words
if you go through and you hash which
again is essentially like oh then hash
each element to an integer then all you
need to do is collect the integers sort
them and count how many you have and
then you can just pre allocate the
buckets and be able to put things in
those places so that lets you be able to
for example sort things by a combination
of columns and kind of it just ends up
being like a faster sort overall and I
guess I guess I bring this up because
the same sorts of optimizations apply
for sorting as you can get with like
summing or finding the minimum in a
particular bucket the same idea where
when you can scan and know that you have
already the cardinality put through you
can figure out what those values are or
do a grouping operation or sub setting
relatively quickly so
so this expands to be a little more
complicated when you're thinking about
like two columns so like with one column
pretty simple right it's like okay I
have like one two three four that's
awesome but if you have multiple columns
like how do you combine them how do you
take three columns together and end up
with like a unique value for each one so
essentially you start out and you
factorize each one individually so now
you have three columns each of which
have like independent factors in them
and then when you combine them you
essentially like multiply the key space
together so it's like maybe over the
first column and then the second column
is like if the first column has like a
hundred values and the second column you
multiply a hundred third column you do
again and then you sum them together
which ends up with like a unique key for
every element but there's kind of a
problem there right if you that if
you're getting the cross product of all
those columns you have this huge space
and what we were saying before is that
counting sort and all of these things
where you're like going through is
effective because you know that you have
like a really limited set of values
because you can just say okay now I want
like value one value to value three so
to get back to that you actually just do
it again
because you know that you have like a
really small set of values so you just
factorize that cross product and now
magically you're back to where you want
it to be in the beginning you know that
you have some low number of unique
values and that grouping and you're able
to take advantage of all like the kind
of fancy algorithms for that so yeah and
again this means that all the algorithms
that you're right when you want to write
like a algorithm for out aggregating
stuff it means that you don't have to
write like three different algorithms
for all the different ways that you
could have keys and instead you just
have to write like one algorithm that
says I have well one algorithm for every
aggregation type that says I have like
this set of integer labels and it goes
out okay so that's kind of like covering
the set of things that I wanted to talk
about while also leaving you time to ask
me some questions and things like that
so let's just like recap so the key to
doing many small operations in Python
which is essentially the problem with
data is we have to do many small
operations over many elements is to not
do them in Python to do them at numpy or
something like that something else and
then like indexing is one of the core
abstractions and it's all about like
building a mapping behind the scenes
between labels that we care
about and integer indexes that are sort
of like an implementation detail blocks
are like the abstraction through which
we subset and change data the underlying
structure kind of helps you think about
when copies are gonna happen because it
makes it clear that when you're
combining between different D types
together that's when you're gonna end up
with copies or when you're doing fancy
indexing but just as like an aside
copies happen a lot if you're using
pandas you kind of have to just be
prepared that that's the case and there
are definitely a lot of like cool
alternatives that handle that particular
situation better and then finally just
kind of that factorization is this
interesting algorithm that's going on
behind the scenes in pandas and powers
the sort of like fast group by
operations that you have so guys thank
you very much if I'm gonna like take
questions now but I am always interested
if you have like any questions that you
don't ask here hit me up on Twitter
github I'm essentially Jay trattner
on all forms of social media including
Instagram now so there you go or you can
send me an email yeah so thanks so any
questions yes yeah I mean if you if
you're getting like one column then
generally that's just like subsetting I
think the big idea was setting with copy
is that uh is more about just like if
you express the setting in one
expression then you can do the set in
place as opposed to having to make a
copy first or accidentally doing your
operation on a copy but yes that's true
when you're if you operated column wise
that would also be the subsetting kind
of view stuff
so actually so yeah they're blocked by
columns but at some level like the
distinction between rows and columns is
doesn't mean anything in pandas in
particular except for the fact that like
pandas is column oriented in terms of
its storage but like for example if you
wanted to iterate by rows in numpy you
can actually do that like actually numpy
has the ability to to change how its
stride is oriented which then changes
the orientation so candace doesn't
necessarily support that but like under
the hood or working with the values from
a block you can do that absolutely for
well like so if you said hey I have like
I need to add like I have five chunks of
100 items right and you start with like
one big data frame if you did 500
appends or even five appends then you're
gonna have five copies whereas if you
concat all of those objects at once then
you don't end up with as many copies
going on underneath the hood because
it's sort of only consolidating it into
blocks once I think any other questions
and feel free to correct me if you know
better because I yeah it doesn't fit
into memory if the table is so large
that it doesn't fit into memory there
are a bunch of solutions that you can go
to to deal with that and I think there
are really good resources online that
talk about options right because
essentially your options are to do some
kind of like splitting your data into
parts processing each part individually
and then merging it back together one of
the biggest ways you can do that is
using PI tables and hdf because that can
do kind of corene but there's but i mean
part of that is just like if your data
is really that big pandas is absolutely
like a medium data solution it's a it
must fit in memory and can't even take
up all of your memory to do it but
obviously you can like split up the job
oh go ahead
suggested you can like specify types and
the read CSV thing I guess so
essentially like if you're reading in
data you can say to it like I'm pretty
sure this column is going to be this
this comes gonna be something else so
you avoid like the overhead of convert
objects I think beyond that it's
probably something more where like you
construct it as an ende array first and
then pass it into the data frame
constructor I think that's a really good
question if there's a standard way to
involve scythe on in it and I don't
really have it I have an answer offhand
so I think that could be a cool question
to like send out to the PI data mailing
list which is like I think it's like
pandas anyways if you go to the pandas
website there's a couple places where
you can ask questions and I think that
would be like an excellent question with
like a test case and stuff so
cool well guys I think we got you know
relatively perfect time lives like the
40 minutes and I'm supposed to have for
this but with Q&A so thank you guys very
much for coming I really appreciate it